バンカラジオ俺の名前は天才小学生す最近
は荒野行動にはまっ
[音楽]
てるに勉強しこれは単なるゲームなんか
じゃないよ荒野コードは今年で7周年を
迎える大人気のゲームなんだ証をかけた
大会も開催されててもはや単なるゲーム
じゃなくてEスポーツだようるさい初戦は
ゲームでしょ俺が稼げることを証明して
あげるよできるわけないでしょ
はいこれ賞金あんたプロゲーマーになり
なさいけけけちゃけけけけけあんたこれに
出るの
よチーム対抗戦
[拍手]
かこれから大会に向けてみで練習をする
準備はか
あ物資を拾う時は動き
続けろ聞いた逃げないで敵と戦えぽいぽい
ぽぽぽいぽいポ言うと東の敵をショット
ガンで撃つ
なここでアスターフォローしてなきゃダメ
なんだ分かったか
はい
お絶対に優勝してみんなで賞金やけにする
ぞ
ああ今日はお母さんがご馳するから好きな
だけ食べ
なさいなんか気持ち悪い
[音楽]
な屋根ちゃんの賞金を使ってこいう生活だ
ちマニ
マニマニお客様大丈夫ですかあちょっと
ご飯が追いつけ
てそそれで賞金はどうやって分配し
ましょうかしら賞金はチームのみんなで
山開きするよへあんた私にお金を渡す約束
はどこに行ったのよ約束そんなの最初から
してないしごちさ
[音楽]
皆様本日はお集まりいただき誠に
ありがとうござい
ますあれは大会常連の頭脳オタク
チームこっちは全回大会優勝の最強幼稚
エンジチーム皆さんには実際にゲームの
世界に入って戦ってもらいますゲームの
世界に入るあれちゃんとてたかなここに
書いてあるだろそんなの分かるわけない
[拍手]
だろそれではゲームを開始し
[音楽]
ます本当にゲームの世界だ
すごいみんな加工するぞ
これで武器は揃っ
た敵
だゲームみたいにうまくいかない
な敵だそっちは2人に任せたぞ
全然当たらないよ
[音楽]
こ交代しますだからもう撃たない
で
[音楽]
う馬ってやっぱバカね
相手はアサルトライフルこっちは
スナイパー遠距離はこっちの方が有利
[音楽]
だよし周囲に敵なし安全確認よし物資の
覚悟が最優これじゃあ行く
[音楽]
ぞ悔しいよ
あおい大丈夫か怖いおい大丈夫か
おい行け大丈夫
か榴弾だ
逃げろ現実はゲームみたいに行かないよタ
く
ほシトガ
ゲットち外し
た見つけたぞゆうとショットガンが
スナイパーに勝てるわけないだろ引け来
[拍手]
[音楽]
待てマメロだ
よしろいぜあっちは順調そうだ
な撃て
[音楽]
エリアが縮小し始めてるこっちから攻める
しか
ない行け
そんなくしたって
無駄もう降参すれば
[音楽]
何が起きた
くそ
お母さん誰
だ
えじゃーん
れよしよしよし
[音楽]
あんたが賞金を分けるつもりがない
なら私が直接手に入れてやるわ
わただでさえ力の強いお母さんに中で戻し
たらほら逃げ回ってるだけじゃ勝てないわ
よほら待ちなさい
どこ行っ
たそこ
ねやるじゃ
ない
行け目が見えなくっ
たって息子の居場所ぐらい分かるわ
よた玉切れ
切れ安全地帯がなくなるとダメージを
食らい
続ける私もうダメか
も
よしなんでねちゃん残念ながら私の勝ち
よやみやみやみ
やみ今だ
[音楽]
やみ聞いたお前生きてたのかあずっと逃げ
てたら生き残っちゃった
俺がお母さんの気を引く聞いたあは頼んだ
ぞえちょちょっと待っ
てよ
おということでバカ小学生チームの優勝
だおめでとう
[拍手]
[音楽]
けけけけけけけけ
あんた何してん
のやっぱりプロゲーマーは楽な仕事じゃ
ないしちゃんと勉強することにしてよや
ちゃんあんたは一緒ゲムだけしなさい全然
嬉しくない
よ今回の動画は荒野コドとのタイアップ
でした荒野コドはサービス開始から7年で
今始めたらたくさんの得がついてるよの者
確定無料ガチャログインするだけでなんと
777金券かiPadProがゲット
できるよ詳しくは概要欄に記載してある
からみんなチェックしてね一緒にプレイし
て
楽しもうちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最初はグチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録JA